joining us now with more former Director
of National Intelligence John Radcliffe
Mr director thank you very much for
being here so it's President's Day he
could have gone I don't know the
Washington or Lincoln Memorial you know
that'd be fitting on a President's Day
uh instead or East Palestine for people
who are suffering instead he's over in
Ukraine pledging even more for that
effort there yet we also this is another
aspect to this too Mr director the
Communist Chinese have just sent their
uh their foreign minister at the same
time to Moscow so as we spend more in
Ukraine China and Russia seem to be
getting closer
well Pete you know even if you you know
look at how badly the Biden
Administration has mismanaged uh Ukraine
up to this point a war that many of us
believe a strong president could have
avoided we we believe that yes it was
Biden's weakness in Afghanistan that
prompted uh Putin to move on Ukraine in
the first place even if you set that
aside if you set aside that on the
second day of the Russian invasion Biden
essentially wanted to surrender Ukraine
remember he offered zielinski a ride out
of the country uh if you set that aside
and you set aside that for the past year
uh no matter whether we're talking about
Stinger missiles or javelins or
anti-artillery or tanks the Biden
Administration and delivering support
has been slow and late and indecisive
even when you said all that aside Pete
it's just hard to Fathom what a blunder
this was the sen that this National
Security team would send him five
thousand miles away to Ukraine when they
haven't sent him 250 miles away uh to
East Palestine for for him to go and
talk about Ukrainian not just providing
weapons Pete but but talking about
welfare and Ukraine pensions and support
to the Ukrainian people when when
there's a trained derailment in an
environmental disaster you know uh This
truly is a Ukraine uh first Ohio last
policy and and you're right at all at
the same while this only encourages and
emboldens China to to help Russia and
for them to work together in what has
been and will continue to be you know a
multi-directional assault on American
Supremacy that they that they have done
for the last two years and we can expect
to continue for the next two years
you talked about Vladimir Putin's
calculation as it pertained to Ukraine
and I think you're right uh about that
they smelled weakness they spelled an
opportunity they went for it just like
they did under Obama but when it comes
to the Communist Chinese uh and what is
their calculation in their involvement
in Ukraine and how much is it that does
it have to do with their view of
Washington hey we can get away with this
and at the same time week in America
well everyone saw what happened in
Afghanistan Pete China certainly did but
make no mistake Pete uh China has been
involved in Ukraine since day one the
day that China said uh we'll take from
Russia all of the oil and gas that you
want to sell us they essentially said to
Vladimir Putin will fund your war
against Ukraine so you know now that
they're talking about you know getting
more directly involved with weapons and
ammunition I mean it's really
um it's not a whole lot different from
what they've already been doing in fact
I suspect that they've been providing
lethal late already through the Wagner
group providing drones and other things
so they're going to continue to uh to to
support Russia against uh you know to
work with Russia against us because
there are no consequences Pete that's
the calculation you know they a million
Americans died from uh from a virus that
they haven't been confronted about a
hundred thousand Americans have died
from fentanyl that they haven't been
confronted about a spy balloon just flew
over our whole country and not only did
we not get an apology they've
essentially demanded an apology from us
while we return their spycraft to them
no no offense is too great they've been
able to get away with everything with
this Administration and and why wouldn't
they see this as a window of opportunity
I hate to say Pete but the fear of many
of us is that they see a two-year window
of opportunity for continued aggression
that may not exist after two more years
yeah continue to gather intelligence
continue to pump people and deadly drugs
across our Southern border while working
with the cartels and continue to poison
the mines
that's the concern is that they'll move
militarily on Taiwan while there's a
window of opportunity and essentially
you know um we've given no indications
that they're ever going to be considered
by the Biden Administration anything but
a friendly competitor because that's
what we keep telling them no matter what
offense they commit no matter what
aggression against our country and our
citizens
they just keep getting away with it
yeah well we hold hands with Ukraine as
if that is the largest strategic
imperative on planet Earth right now
well next to climate change too uh
director Radcliffe thank you very much
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else